j'ai demandé à camille sur le corner
avec elle est prise par l de partir
premier poteau et charlotte on les tire
au deuxième au deuxième et à personne
l'équipe d' hec paris ne laisse rien au
hasard ce samedi 23 avril ses joueuses
vouloir remporter la saint gobain
football cup un rendez-vous qui oppose
les écoles d'ingénieurs et de commerce
de toute la france pour cela elle
s'entraîne trois fois par semaine depuis
plusieurs mois ce jour-là à
clairefontaine c'est le jour de vérité
là on est surexcité on est hyper fier
hyper contente il ya aussi un bon esprit
qu'on fait quand même entre les écoles
on est là pour défendre notre école
vraiment quoi mais on s'amuse bien entre
nous il ya un bon esprit qui règne dans
le tournoi c'était qui basée à jouy en
josas fait partie des 24 écoles
présentent ce week-end dans les yvelines
à l'occasion de cette coupe de france
étudiante depuis dix ans l'événement
réunit chaque année plusieurs milliers
de joueurs de l'hexagone en soit ces
maillots ses couleurs on a son nom
dessus on est aidé pour les déplacements
la réservation des terrains et bien
entendu le graal final il est de venir
ici pendant trois jours disputer les
phases finales de chaque coupe de france
et celle des écoles de commercial des
ingénieurs en parallèle de la
compétition l'événement se veut
également professionnel avec
l'entreprise sponsor de l'événement
venus dénicher les futurs talents en les
observant pas directement sur le terrain
c'est plus de les changes qui se passe
en bord de terrain on va comprendre un
peu leur projet professionnel leur
expliquer les métiers qu'on peut avoir
au sein du groupe nous on a pas mal
d'offres à pourvoir on a en tout ou à
peu près de 1500 offre de stage
alternance cdi et donc bah voilà essayer
de trouver le bon match sur le terrain
après trois jours de compétition
l'équipe féminine hc s'est imposé dans
sa catégorie face à l'edhec lille en
finale au total quatre équipes sont
qualifiées pour la grande finale de la
saint gobain football cup à
s'affronteront en fin d'année